(cell phone rings)
Hello?
Yeah, yeah,
Natty Legs.
The people want
another performance.
Oh, God.
You got to give it to 'em; you
got to give 'em what they want.
I got to get
my ready on.
You got to get
out there, Natty.
Natty Legs, bitch.
♪ I got a show tonight
at the comedy joint ♪
♪ But before I hit the stage,
I get my shit on point ♪
♪ I get my muscles loose
with the Jacuzzi fog ♪
♪ Then I get a portrait painted
of me and my dog ♪
♪ I sit for a portrait
of me and Mayor Cutie ♪
♪ Then I get it airbrushed
on by booty ♪
♪ Then they paint in on a cake,
I only take one bite ♪
♪ (bleep) those starving kids,
gotta keep my "sitch" tight ♪
♪ Drink 40 cups of Throat Coat
while they're cooking my quail ♪
♪ And after all that,
I have my money detailed ♪
♪ Gotta have your cream steamed,
there's germs on money ♪
♪ And when it's all wrinkled,
gotta fluff and fold, honey ♪
♪ Gotta take another bath
in prehistoric mud ♪
♪ B-B-Back to my room
where I get new blood ♪
♪ The only blood
that works for me is ♪
♪ Blue blood 'cause...
Natty Legs, bitch ♪
♪ And a migrant named Lionel
alphabetizes my vinyl ♪
♪ While I dine with my gyno
a-a-and my jewelry designer ♪
♪ Right before the show,
I get primped and weighed ♪
♪ Then I go to the network,
it's time to get paid ♪
♪ I elegant, that's what I be ♪
♪ So damn fancy,
got a diamond pussy ♪
♪ D-D-D-Diamond pussy,
d-d-d-diamond pussy ♪
♪ D-D-D-D... Diamond pussy ♪
(meows)
No, no, no, no.
No.
Natasha, the budget for
your special is out of control.
We've got to keep
this thing simple. Look.
I can show you market research
that proves
people do not
want to see effort.
Uh-uh. I didn't
get into this business to read.
Okay, then
I'll summarize it for you, okay?
Specials aren't special anymore.
And you're making yours
way too special.
You're spending too much money.
I haven't even
finished my intro yet.
I know. I can still
hear the music.
This is the perfect time
to rein it in.
Have you seen
these Louis C.K. specials?
He literally
gets off the bus,
he wipes mustard off his shirt,
he does the show in a T-shirt.
That's
a producer's dream.
I can get you a T-shirt.
That's what people want.
No frills.
Okay, I'll think about it.
Thought about it.
Hell no.
Okay, it's really annoying
when you talk
in tempo to the music, okay?
'Cause it sounds
like you're rapping.
And I'm sorry,
but you cannot call the special
Diamond Pussy.
But I had it polished
for the show.
Okay, it looks amazing.
But we have got to stop
spending money.
Shut the hell up, Mister...
Wearing-A-Suit-Man.
Table flip.
Don't flip my...
Don't flip the table.
It's glass. Please.
♪ Man, (bleep) this
patriarchal society ♪
♪ Name of this special
still be Diamond Pussy ♪
♪ That was a waste of my time,
my show starts in ten ♪
♪ And I still got
a whole bunch of errands ♪
♪ I got business, bitch,
I need forever stamps ♪
♪ They're such a good value,
got me super amped ♪
♪ One more thing
I need to address ♪
♪ An unfortunate by-product ♪
♪ Of saying yes ♪
♪ Down to the clinic,
I'm a superstar ♪
♪ All those bitches
know who I are ♪
♪ 'Cause I have a career ♪
♪ I ain't having babies ♪
♪ The price of two babies
equals five Mercedes ♪
♪ I need another abortion,
so I pay the fee ♪
♪ If I get two more ♪
♪ Sixth one's free ♪
Do you want
to use this one today?
♪ Nah, that's okay,
I'll pay, bitch ♪
♪ While they get the baby
they massage my legs ♪
I eat steak and eggs ♪
♪ Then I have the waiter
bring a light dessert ♪
♪ Bye-bye, baby,
mama's eating sherbert ♪
♪ I eat steak and eggs
and lamb and ham ♪
♪ Post my meal and abortion
all on Instagram ♪
♪ I get away with this, y'all,
'cause I'm famous and wealthy ♪
♪ Always got time for a selfie ♪
♪ I gotta finish this shit,
get my ass to the club ♪
♪ I'm-a do my show high
on abortion drugs ♪
♪ I feel ten pounds lighter,
even with the steak ♪
♪ And now my body's back
to its pre-op weight ♪
♪ It takes a lot of maintenance
to keep all this juicy ♪
♪ And that's how I keep
this diamond pussy ♪
(meows)
♪ Now I'm ready for my show,
I call it what I want ♪
♪ 'Cause they want this shiny
pussy from China to Vermont ♪
♪ (bleep) Ben & Jerry,
they're a couple of wussies ♪
♪ Binge on a pint
of diamond pussy ♪
♪ Diamond pussy,
d-d-d-diamond pussy ♪
♪ D-d-d-d... ♪
♪ Diamond pussy ♪
(meows)
♪ I elegant ♪
♪ That's what I be ♪
♪ So damn fancy,
got a diamond pussy ♪
♪ D-d-d-diamond pussy,
d-d-d-diamond pussy ♪
EMCEE:
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Natasha Leggero!
(cheering and applause)